true story you probably saw the video at
the UN today President Trump told world
leaders that his administration has
accomplished more than any in US history
and the whole audience laughed the whole
UN just burst out laughing and Trump was
furious cuz for a few seconds he
accidentally made some foreigners happy
that was not his intention yeah yeah you
actually see him react because that was
not the reaction I thought I was gonna
get I know and then later he said he
meant it as a joke which means if he
says it's Americans now we can laugh we
can laugh yeah we're now allowed to
laugh very strange in his speech at the
UN he also said this President Trump
said that Iran's leaders so chaos and
destruction yeah
Trump then said come on man that's my
thing Dunkin Donuts is in the news now
I've got your attention we're all tired
of Trump let's talk about Dunkin Donuts
okay
there's a fatigue even when we go over
the jokes I know we have to mention
what's happening in the news and
politics and Mars like I know I know and
then we get to the Dunkin Donuts token
like they're gonna like this okay Dunkin
Donuts announced that next year they
will shorten their name from Dunkin
Donuts to just Dunkin yeah and their
customers will shorten the name of their
disease from diabetes to just be teased
what's you got I got babies that's what
I got I want in on that the investment
banking firm goldman sachs joined thank
you sir I lost everything he's naked so
naked got in the crowd
no home nothing the Investment Banking
from goldman sachs joined Instagram in
an attempt to endear themselves to a new
generation goldman sachs joined
Instagram yeah today Goldman's posted a
meme that said we're the reason your
parents lost your childhood home you got
a hashtag for that one hashtag bubble
yeah scientists have developed a robotic
skin that can make stuffed animals
appear to come to life it's being hailed
as a breakthrough for people who like to
scare the [ __ ] out of small children why
what does it mean I don't know weird I
don't know like just to see the stuffed
animal coming at you the night a little
Chucky Starbucks announced its closing a
hundred and fifty stores
yeah and get this all on the same block
why did you get happier when I left what
was that all about
yay it's over
you